We will use again a visual metaphor to describe what a process is.
Continuing with a toy shop as an example,
you can think of a process as an order of toys.
An order of toys has its state of execution, it requires some parts, and
a temporary holding area, and even may require some special hardware.
For instance, it's state of execution, may include the completed toys, the toys
that are waiting to be built, that are part of that order, and other things.
Building the toys may require various parts, like plastic pieces, wooden pieces,
and these come in different containers, or
we may require some other temporary holding area for the pieces.
And, finally, to actually build a toy, we may need some special hardware.
We may need sewing machines, glue guns, or other types of tools.
So, how does all of this then compare to a process in an operating system?
Well, a process also has a state of execution described with
the program counter, the stack pointer.
All this information is used by the operating system to decide how
to schedule the process, how to swap between multiple processes, and
for other management tasks.
In order to execute, the process needs some data.
There's some state in registers.
And, it also has some temporary holding area.
For instance, it occupies state in memory.
Finally, executing a process may require some special hardware like
I/O devices like discs, or network devices.
The operating system has to manage these devices and
control which of the processes that are perhaps executing concurrently at
the same time gets access to which hardware components.
This is similar to what would happen in a toy shop where the toy shop
manager has to control how the special hardware, like the sewing machine or
the glue gun, are used.
Which particular order of toys will get to be assigned the usage of
these more designated hardware components.